did Allah appear to the mountain okay
yes he says he showed his face to the
mountain and what no he didn't no Allah
says no in in the Quran when he spoke to
Moses he says yeah yeah yeah to in what
way you have no idea yeah so abas says
uh says that he knows how Allah appeared
to the mountain okay let's let's see his
interpretation inshallah let's see he
said that Allah showed his pinky
according to okay okay never I've never
heard of this this interesting never
heard of that so what do you think no I
never heard of it it showed his pinky to
the mountain what way did he like
make it appear in creation like you're
proposing if you show something yes yes
so is that
visual his finger entered the creation
like what is this come on very good so
that creation no absolutely not you have
no knowledge of this claim except for
what the says when it speaks about him
showing his pinky to the mountain in
what way when they asked about this
Muhammad said and he actually gestured
with his finger how it happened okay
never heard of this take this to a
person of knowledge but but okay but
don't reject it no I don't I I reject
what you're proposing that Allah has
entered creation why are you rejecting
whenas and Muhammed said so here it is
this this is something that you're doing
and you're imagining a huge enormous
Pinky and what is
this do you even
know can Allah enter into his creation
Allah yes Allah he brother what are you
saying brother what are you saying no
Allah is created no no no he said Can
Allah enter into his own okay brother
what is Allah who is Allah who is this
Allah is the creator is yes the Creator
that is he is he created himself okay
what Avery what was the question again
he ask can Allah enter creation brother
don't ever say yes to that what are you
saying wah that is disgusting don't say
it no bro bro I would't finish mate let
me okay I apologize I apologize what I'm
saying is Allah can enter into creation
like in the world no he cannot what are
you on bro let me finish bro let me
finish let me finish pleas what are you
say let me finish let me finish please
yeah okay what I'm saying is Allah can
enter his own creation he can but he
won't do it because it does not beit his
majesty no no no Allah can cannot what
is this Allah is uncreated finished
there is no after that what did the
prophet sallallahu alaihi was say he
says when we go back and back where did
this come from and we get to Allah what
do we do we stop this is an order from
the prophet we don't ever into K and
Allah into this is Blasphemous and you
will be questioned on the day of
judgment for the statements that you say
so don't get don't sit here and try to
be confused and play with it don't play
with that Allah is uncreated finished
you feel me no but he he didn't say
created or uncreate he said he said
brother can Allah die Allah no he can't
die finished you see it you see it don't
don't ever say those statements aren't
the heavens created by bro okay Allah is
the creator of the seven Heavens but
where is Allah Allah himself is above
his throne if you want to get Allah does
descend to the nearest Heaven yeah okay
f one 100 well
1,145 so yes he does enter creation okay
yes yes I have a question yeah Allah
says no matter where you turn your face
he is there I look down he's there I
look up he's there so is Allah not the
most high is he down what is this he's
wherever we turn his face is there
metaphysical when we're speaking about
Allah is not known to humankind so for
any person to even try Del into or even
try to understand why does it say that
he
descend descend would be to change
physical location from A to B okay
yes yes movement Allah also says and
musim too so if you want both Allah also
says he has two right hands Allah yes
Allah also says he has a face what do we
do with
his
yes there's nothing comparable to him
descend in a way that we don't
understand except the Angels mixed up um
Adam for Allah so at least some part of
Adam looked like Allah well what do you
w what is these
statements w What are what whoo what do
you what do you guys I have a question
what is this W I would never bro wah if
I I'm a Muslim I would never get on a
pedal and say things that you guys say
about Islam what are you say angel
saying it are you saying so just real
quick did did the answer did we get the
answer can all creation no no what is
this says
yes canot what are you let me let me
speak says yes yeah let let me let me
speak now please it hurts my heart to
hear no no let let me speak AR okay okay
ay Avery when you say Allah can Allah
enter into creation can you explain it
to me please what do you mean by that
like if he wanted to visit you could he
can he walk among the Earth if he wanted
to okay excellent Allah can do that but
Allah Allah doesn't do that because it
doesn't yes exactly
okay Avery Avery yes can can Allah
become sorry can your God become a
Muslim what can your CHR your version of
Christian God can you become a Muslim no
that that'll be unrighteous yeah there
you go this one this is what we're
telling you Islam for God to come in
here that will be unrighteous as well
unri this is what we're trying to
explain to
you unrighteous is do you know what
unrighteous is unrighteous yeah yeah
like doing something wrong yeah like
sinful it's yeah yeah morally it's
morally evil yeah Mor god is perfect and
holy he cannot by therefore go against
his nature and be sinful thank you very
much that's why it's a contradictory
question to ask can the Christian God
the true God of the heavens and the
Earth Yahweh become Muslim because that
would be sinful to be a muslim okay
we're also saying yeah God can't enter
his own creation because said he could
against his
nature you've answered you just answered
us thank you very much Avery thank you
said he could well this is great
he you just destroyed the Christ Bel you
said that he could yeah I said he could
if he wants to but because so Allah
wanted he could sin no I said come to
the world okay so come to the world
would it be sinful for him to come to
the world it wouldn't be but it'll be
more why are you equating that when I
said Allah can't be that God the true
God cannot become a Muslim because
becoming a Muslim is sinful being a
Muslim is denying and rejecting the true
God and denying the Christ and the
Messiah that's all of that that's all
that comes with Muslim and having four
wives y y all of that is sinful
according to God so he couldn't do that
that's against his nature why would
sinful or morally wrong yeah it's all
the same why would for him to enter into
creation yeah sorry is it sinful for
your God to enter into creation why
sorry sorry can can can one of you is it
is it sinful for your God to enter into
cre into creation it's morally wrong
morally because God yeah God doesn't do
that wait why is it morally wrong wait
Bob why you speaking it doesn't it
doesn't beit his majesty no why is it
morally wrong just because it doesn't
befit his majesty doesn't mean it's
sinful why is itally wrong because God
does do certain things like that so so
God is wrong why is it you're saying
that it's morally wrong why is it
morally wrong why is it sinful for God
if he wanted to to come and visit and
walk among walk on earth because God
doesn't do that kind of stuff it doesn't
his majesty I've just told you how do
you know because God God has told us
that where how where where like for
instance what does Allah say that I do
not enter into creation where does he
say that if you if you look at it Allah
Allah's nature Allah doesn't mingle with
human beings does a mix with human
beings okay what is it where does it say
that Allah will cannot and would not
come uh enter into into his creation
where does he say that you said he
wouldn't do that where does Allah say
that wouldn't do that God doesn't do
that
Avery God say where does he say in the
Quran or inth yeah Allah can come yeah
and stay vers 143 where chapter 7 verse
143 Bob this is Bob what's your name
brother you keep your you keep your name
uncovered you like to keep no told Avery
my proper name okay is his name Abu
Baker actually yeah yeah that's my
proper name yeah alhamdulillah brother
listen listen when you start getting
into metaphysical what is Allah this
that and the third it's very simple done
that's it there's nothing comparable to
him so to say that Allah became a man he
is now comparable to something this goes
against the Quran verse finished yeah
yeah no bro bro I agree with you yeah no
there don't don't delve into specifics
about this why you twisting your brain
it's so
simple that's it there's nothing
comparable to him so he's comparable to
something uh then it's finished right
what he can't become a man because
that's done it's not it's it's a simple
it's a very simple thing bro but they
bro they're they're they're not here to
speak about impossibilities and
possibilities because this is I wouldn't
say it's subjective but these are more
logical philosophical proofs evidences
let them speak what they want to tell us
as Christians that we have to believe
that Jesus Christ is God or else
I've spoken I've spoken to Avery about
job job 25 yeah about anyone born of a
woman yeah it's not pure so Jesus that
definitely puts Jesus there but yet he
goes around and say Jesus is God the
Bible clearly states anyone born of a
woman I'm not about to allow you guys to
waste more of my time you know enter
into creation where where does Allah say
that he cannot enter into his creation
or or will not ever enter into creation
where does he make that statement the St
the statement's not in the Quran thank
you why did Bob say that no I said I
said God
doesn't bro I said God and with you
Avery with your questions yeah you make
it look like God come into creation and
leave with human beings is that what you
meant in that sense can Allah if he
wanted to come and walk on the earth can
he come walk on water if he wanted to
could he come and stand in a football
stadium if he wanted to can can he stick
his hand in the atmosphere or something
if he wanted to he can do it but there
are certain things that he doesn't do
because he doesn't live with his majesty
I've told you how do you know that that
doesn't beit his majesty for instance
what you guys believe that God can
become a man I didn't ask that I'm just
asking about enter into
creation not becoming a man or anything
like that enter creation yes or no Avery
but do you believe do you believe Jesus
was God do you believe that stop asking
me about Jesus and your what is wrong
with you guys
okay I just what wrong
with I'm not I'm not I'm not gonna ask
you questions anymore okay Christians
believe Jesus was God okay now God for
us yeah in Islam yeah doesn't do that
kind of stuff because it doesn't beit
his majesty where do you say that said
har the brother said har it doesn't beit
his majesty okay I got
question it says there's no it says
there's nothing like Allah okay what you
what do you what's your question brother
in Christ okay so Adam Adam was created
right okay yes just established that
right was Adam created yes or no yes I
okay simple simple simple question easy
easy all created Adam with his own hands
Avery all right Aver okay as according
toari
7516 was Adam in the heavens when he was
created or was he on Earth in creation
sorry go that knowledge is not known to
me perhaps I don't know ask somebody
else so sah albari is not clear then huh
no I don't know the's not clear sah
albari is not clear it's pretty simple
just I'm not sure the answer to
question no I'm just not sure the
question but to make it pretty simple
before you do that let me read this out
Allah can't be compared to anything but
he has 99 attributes Muslim logic their
answer is literally is literally to bury
their heads in the sand when confronted
with this contradiction your brain on
Islam thank you so much for for the chat
and that input could have said it any
better okay brother you asked me a very
basic question brother that's a very
good
question listen second up
um you say Allah has created Adam with
his own hands oh that's not me I just
want clarification that's not me that's
okay fine notari that's the Quran no
it's in the Quran yeah a is right
that's the one I was referring to it's
Allah subh Tal's own words yes yes yes
say do say ay you're right don't say it
I know I'm right I'm a h I've been
telling y'all that you're not you're not
H but you are right wow hate okay haters
but you say well the says Allah created
Adam with his own hand no it say it says
in the Quran as well yeah yeah yes I
know the verse but he's quoting from
brother bro you have and I have no idea
this event took place yeah we do we no
we have no idea how it took place as if
Allah stck for Allah took his hands like
this reached in and picked up dirt you
have no idea perhaps he was perhaps he
outside
say the angels to prostrate themselves
before Adam okay yes the body because it
was one of the few things that Allah
made with his own hands okay but yes how
was it from outside of creation did he
pick it up like this
I'm saying it could have you don't have
any knowledge of this event I don't have
his hands entered into Creation in order
to create Adam that it no it does not
say no then Adam wasn't in creation when
he was created God sent angels to go and
get Bob take a second let's make this
very simple you have no knowledge of the
claim that you're trying to bring forth
you're trying to make a case to make a
to make a comparison to the problem of
of God being outside of space and time
and
and then one of them and entering and
making a comparison to Islam No I'm just
asking for clarification on this one
section the clarification Allah
obviously is entering into creation to
create Adam or Adam is not even in
creation to make the clarification very
simple okay very very simple you don't
know I don't know ask someone of
knowledge that's it wait maybe this is
one of the unclear verses maybe maybe
one some of Knowledge walk yourself to a
Masid ask them these questions and see
what they say elusive perhaps you
wouldn't know ask a person everything
very simple ask elive everybody
everybody in Islam is elusive elusive
guys guys guys come on you can't you
can't use the verses like that and say
everything is elusive you can't do that
guys we get it's
elusive with his own hands yeah yeah
that's enough for us to know we don't
need to know everything
like the brother said har said yeah what
what Allah says he created with his own
hands that's all we need to know we
don't need to know everything Beyond was
that in creation or outside of creation
because if it was in creation then Allah
is entering into creation it's outside
of creation okay listen listen problem
this is the most simplest thing ever and
there's two things to mention here okay
the first one let's make it clear I
don't know Avery doesn't know Bob
doesn't know wait listen you don't know
so what what do what do us five what do
us five do here do we sit here and say
this maybe no go to a person of
knowledge they might have an answer for
you now listen the only the only reason
you bring this because if we have the
same problem in your Doctrine then we
can't say anything about the Trinity
that's what I'm saying but there is okay
but listen there is no comparison oh
let's make this very clear there is zero
comparison between a one and only and a
one and three there is no comparison and
there will never be a comparison problem
there is no comparison
reading out Super Chat I'm reading out
super chats y'all gotta be quiet when I
do this okay go one way apologetic says
haiz and Mom logic spitting facts out
here and then we got another Super Chat
saying you can't use scriptures against
us yeah
yeah what's the US who is the US
USL the rest of the Muslim cons yes yes
the Muslim you can't use vers is against
us no the Muslim the whole entire Muslim
Community is us the dead
scholar the prophet people they say that
you're not allowed to use scriptures
against us alhamdulillah okay ask a
person of knowledge YouTu if you
actually want to know go to a person of
knowledge and the same if I don't know
something about don't be throwing up the
CRI sign
me wait
wait in the same way if I don't know
anything about the the Christian Bible
you think I would go to a Muslim panel
hey guys what about Christian no I'm no
W I came here that's why that's how I
met you yeah I want to know about why
you believe what you believe I'm not
gonna last question last question last
question does Allah descend to the
lowest Heaven at the third of the night
again in a way we don't understand
that's but does he do it does he do it
and a way we don't understand ald
problem does he yeah and a way we don't
understand so yes he ENT creation but
only doesn't you have no knowledge of
this no I have knowledge right here
so he Muslim you have no know two
sources hundreds of years removed from
the actual events you have you have no
knowledge of this claim but you were you
never seen Allah's hands Ali's never
seen it
either just pause what is it I want to
know does Allah descend to the lowest
Heaven yes or no okay it states this
inside the what the authentic Hadith in
what way does Allah descend again I'm
just asking I'm answering your question
the metaphysical of Allah his face is
everywhere we turn Allah says this in
the Quran doesn't matter where you turn
your face Allah is there here here here
but listen Allah is the most high how is
this possible he's above his throne how
how is how is he here if I'm looking
down it doesn't make sense the
metaphysical of Allah is not known to
mankind so he is so he is in creation
then Brother come on what is this if he
turns and his face is there is he in
creation how in what way what why what
we already clarified I don't know you
don't know no one knows here actually we
do know why he descends because
alari okay why does he descend and how
does he desend and makes sense it's
actually for a physical reason yeah okay
what's the physical reason yes to
forgive the forgive the people forgive
to
hear read read the read who is calling
upon me yes for forgiveness T yes we
know of this I may answer him not Jes
who's calling upon me I can't hear you
up on my Throne I gotta come down here
to the lowest Heaven on the last third
of the night to hear you because I can't
hear you up there is a lot hearing is it
obviously not
thir okay so so you accept
does let me let me respond to the
brother in Christ inshallah wait where
just a second just a second thir
California or New York just a second you
accept Sahari and you accept that Allah
descends but then you reject you reject
the part of the Quran what he says he's
all hearing and now you're trying to act
like he has to descend because he can't
hear is this it's just that your
contradict each other your Source this
is the point nowhere near a
contradiction nothing to do has nothing
to do with us picking and choosing or
picking a fight it has everything to do
with your sources not being consistent
in its theology when we point out the
inconsistencies you're saying oh your
motive is evil oh you're just not
understanding oh you hate the prophet
nothing to do with that it's just
inconsistent he's all hearing why does
he have to come down to he then okay
that that makes no
sense creation why enter into the lowest
Heaven yeah makes no sense what are we
supposed to do okay supposed to be look
and Islam is supposed to be on the fit
on your fitra right supposed to be your
natural disposition you're supposed to
know this automatically Islam is
supposed to be um empathetic to your
natural inclination it's supposed to be
simple that's what y'all give out the da
about that's the sells pitch is that
it's much more simpler than believing
that God is three uh and yet and also
won at the same
timey can you me directly meisten okay
fine no no I didn't say fault or whose
fault it is this that and the third I
made it quite clear before we even
delved into no I made it quite clear you
don't know I don't know brother in
Christ doesn't know Abu Bak doesn't know
brother Christ does know it's quite it's
quite simple you guys don't have the
answer you're posing something that you
think is a contrib read you haven't
spoke to a person of knowledge no am I a
person of knowledge is no just
regular ask go to it take what you said
it's so incomplete you can't even
understand it unless you go to a
personal knowledge yes brother take what
you said is it unclear okay take what
you said that's unclear I want you to
take it go to a Masid and if you don't
go to the Masid you just don't want to
know and that's fine you will never know
why you could die upon why do I have to
more than the people at the Masid over
200 years after yes yes of course I said
take what you POs to me and take it to a
Masid and see what see what they you
know what I would love to do that I'm G
do that please take it make a video of
it inshallah if you want to take your
questions take your questions to a m and
see what they say brother you live you
live there how are you there I see you
in a video it was it was random I was
just scrolling through my page on my uh
uh recommended and I seen you he met him
okay aldah I just want to watch it you
live near him no I don't okay go to
person you have a master some I have a m
questions there I have when I have
question Christianity I come to you guys
you have question of Islam if we don't
know okay we don't know more question
did you have a response to that or no
response to what no brother Christ did
you have a response to that because I
have a question go ahead okay um did
Allah appear to the mountain okay yes he
says he showed his face to the mountain
and what would no he didn't no Allah
says no and in the Quran when he spoke
to Moses he says yeah yeah yeah show to
in what way you have no idea you have no
idea that's the funny thing you have no
idea how you have no idea how actually
EV about said so hold on okay
be sure you're in the same time zone as
Allah When you pray he comes
at hey that's true you got to be in the
right time zone man I'm like man do I
gota is it in California third of the
night is it New York's third of the
night China's third of the night those
are different you know but hey
uh yeah so Abbas says uh says that he
knows how Allah appeared to the mountain
okay let's let's hear his interpretation
inshallah let's see he said that Allah
showed his pinky according to okay okay
I never heard I've never heard of this
this interesting never heard of that so
what do you think no I never heard of it
it showed his pinky to the mountain what
way did he like U make it appear in
creation like you're proposing he says
that he showed his little finger to the
mou yeah and the same way that Allah has
used his hands to create Adam in what
way
again neither of us have no knowledge
the mountain in which he showed a
glimpse of his little finger okay yes
and what way if you show something yes
so yes so yes is that visual Allah Allah
his finger entered the creation like
what is this come on very good so that
Allah creation no absolutely not you
have no knowledge of this claim except
for what the says when it speaks about
him showing his pinky to the mountain in
what way you have no knowledge of this
claim ask person of knowledge just to be
clear he said he said he said that when
they asked about this mammed said and he
actually gestured with his finger how it
happened okay never heard of this take
this to a person of knowledge but okay
but don't reject it no I don't I I
reject what you're proposing that Allah
has entered creation why are you
rejecting when I Abbas and Muhammad said
so okay did they say he entered creation
they said that he appeared into the
mountain by showing his his little
finger and he did like this and what way
by doing this here it is this this is
something that you're doing and you're
imagining I'm you're huge enormous py
and what is this what said
do you even
know let me post something let me post
something there is no question in
Muhammad s alaihi wasall if he says
something it's authentic it's authentic
we take it then he did enter creation
but listen what you're proposing is so
irrational iral it is so
irrational no it is completely
irrational what you're proposing you're
trying to make one question no no before
we move on to the second let me just
make this very clear you're trying to
make the case that
Allah took his p and took creation what
are you saying okay okay fine let's say
no okay fine let's say I accept it let's
say he took his pinky what he says he
took his pinky and enter enter it did
not enter creation this is Allah's
uncreated you
saying bro no one is questioning
Muhammad s oh yes you are no you said
that his pinky inter creation I said
okay fine ask you no we answer this
question but then I ask you when what
way you have no knowledge I showed you
you have no knowledge I showed you
Muhammad did this he showed his little
finger okay you have no knowledge of how
it entered
creation quoting Muhammad said that he
did this when he showed him he he showed
his little finger and did this with his
finger does Allah not say that on the
day of judgment he's gonna wrap up the
Heavens like a scroll you see does this
mean he's gonna wrap it like this and
he's gonna hold and he say he's gonna
hold it in his right hand does that mean
he's gonna hold it like this yeah okay
what is what do we say and there's
nothing comparable to him this AR he's
comparable like you that he has hands
feet
he has a face you have a face my face
this phone has a face not like my face
this
face
last physical features Allah is physical
Fe but he's not physical like how you
are this is the last thing that I I'll
propose to you guys this is the last
thing on this point the of the Prophet
mm we see how big the is you know the
Muslim call the world of yeah it's less
it's low you see how big it is we know
how big the universe is we have a
general
it is gigantic everything in the
observable universe is the first Heaven
the prophet M the first one to the
second is like a ring of the desert
second to the third third to the four so
to say that Allah above the throne took
his pinky and enter what are you saying
you saying saying is M what are you
saying Muhammad Muhammad what the hell
are you saying the brother
not what the hell are you
saying you should be saying it is not
what you guys are proposing what you
guys are proposing is food for what what
it was
visible understand how it happened demon
ask a person of knowledge one last
question one last question who was in
The Burning Bush the burning bush that's
when Allah spoke to Moses well we've
heard of this as well it was an angel it
was the
angel okay I'm not sure where you heard
so the angel says I am Allah your lord
okay okay let uh let me
okay now you're saying okay Allah's
speech entered creation who was in the
bush cuz it said
bless Allah you know Allah is above got
it okay you know Allah is above his
throne yes no okay you don't know that
okay fine because he was one
point in the same way if I if I speak
about the Trinity and I bring an
argument against the Trinity but I
reject that the holy spirit's part of
the Trinity there's nothing to speak
about you don't even accept the basic
Theology of Islam that Allah is above
his what is the point of moving forward
here would just say he's in the bu count
on what time of night it is what you got
to be aware of what time of night it is
what what are you what are you saying
thirdd of the night he's not on his
throne he's in the lowest
Heaven Bush he an angel no okay brother
he says Angel so the angel is your lord
Allah thank you Bob for
commit what is this this is a joke this
is you're the joking you're actually
joking this is funny
yeah okay fine Bob says or abak says an
angel this is not my this is not my
understanding okay it's okay Allah spoke
through what the bush the burning bush
Okay and the Bush was burning and the
leaves were not fallowing amazing it in
the bush Allah is not in the bush in the
same way when it says when it says
blessed is he who is in the bush Okay in
the bush yeah let me ask you question
let me ask you a question this is very
simple say angel okay fine this is very
simple am I in my computer right now or
am I in my room speaking to you come on
W you guys know the answer this is funny
to you guys if I have my phone and I
call a person in China hey y person in
China am I in my phone come on what is
this what is this of course we say
blessed be upon the person who's in the
phone if Allah is above the throne and
he speaks through let's say a bush is he
in the bush what is this you know the
the question answer the question no
Allah is not in the bu when it says
blessed is he who is in the bush who's
in the bush okay bring me the verse I
haven't read this inside the Quran Allah
says I it is I I am your Allah your lord
your exactly I am Allah he just okay
what is this I got you I got he's
speaking through the tree even if he
says bro you know a Muslim is Never
Gonna accept guys really quick what
verse is that again what verse is that
again guys it's slipping my my my my
brain
know yeah what you're posing they're not
going to accept good stuff Bob come on
bro are hilarious
it's it's 20 yeah 20 I give props what
props is do man what what I do know do I
do know the story it's just that I don't
know it like exactly do you remember the
verse um I'm not sure the exact verse
there it is oh there it is okay yes
blessed is he when he reached it he
called saying blessed is whoever is what
chapter is this what chapter is this
this is 27 verse
8 let all open up to it in blessed is he
278 who is in the fire and whoever is
around it and glorified be Allah the
lord of the world yeah I've just told
you he the angel he didn't he keep
ignoring that it's the angel yeah so the
so the angel said I am your lord I am
Allah and all that kind of stuff no no
no I set the one in the fire in the fire
yes the one in the fire where do you get
this from because we understand when
Allah does things yeah the angels are
with yeah what okay yeah okay but Allah
says inide the Quran that Moses spoke to
him directly yeah the
voice okay what verse is this I didn't
even think about that he spoke to Moes
direct yeah so yeah so your your your
interpretation goes out the window
already yeah hey Abu Bakr Allah says
that he spoke to Moses directly but we
know the prophet Muhammad is even higher
in status why because Allah brought him
up to himself he spoke to spoke to him
from behind the veil you see and he
spoke to him directly and this is when
the Salah was decreed for the Muslim you
see spoke directly there's no there's no
intermedi intermediary I want you to
understand where I'm coming from what
I'm saying is Allah spoke to Moses
directly but the one in the fire is not
Allah this what it says watch this it
says but when he reached it he was
called saying blessed is whoever is in
the fire so the voice is talking in from
the fire and whoever is around it who
around the fire Bob if the or Moses mes
Moses is around the fire correct you you
agree Bob yes under the angels as well
and the angels there were no Angels
there what are you talking about who is
there who in the fire where is he
getting this from I have no knowledge of
that you just be making up stuff you
have knowledge I have no knowledge of of
the Angels uh there there are no Angels
there I have no knowledge of that anyway
this is what the next verse says oh
Moses it is I Allah the Mighty the wise
so the one who's in the fire is saying
it is I Allah the mighty and the wise B
no no no the angel no it says bless the
one in the fire he's also in the fire
and blessed is the one who's around it
who's Moses the one who's in the fire
just said he's Allah no it doesn't Avery
he doesn't it doesn't it says the word
in the fire and now understanding in
some Muslims understanding is that's the
angel who is this speaking I've just
told you the voice is Allah got it so we
go so the voice is Allah speaking yes so
Allah speaking from the fire says it is
me Allah right right so it's not an
angel no the one in the fire the one in
the fire is not Allah stop bring stop
committing Shir come on hey
Bob I mean why you have your name Bob I
just Abu Bak you change it you no I
didn't because where I live people
struggle to call my name Bob Abu Bakr so
I just made it short also in my country
where I'm from originally the short name
for Abu Bak is Bob Bob so Bob I want you
to pay attention here Bob Bob it says
remember when Moses said unto his
household look I spy AAR off a fire I
will bring you good I will bring you
Tidings then or bring to you a borrowed
flame that you may warm yourselves but
when he reached it when he reached the
fire right right yes yes go he was
called right saying so he was called we
see the other vers says Moses y y and he
said say blessed is he blessed is
whoever is in the fire and who is
whoever is round about it and glorified
be Allah the lord of the worlds yeah
where where does it say Allah is in the
fire there it says oh Moses it is I
Allah the Mighty the wise yeah so when
he approached the fire Allah is the one
who's speaking from the fire no speaking
the voice is Allah but not the one the
fire the one the fire is not Allah so
who is it that the one that's speaking
is Allah says I am Allah you're saying
an angel is saying I am Allah bro bro
please I want you understand what I'm
saying I said the boys you saying an
angel is saying I am Allah no when Allah
says whoever bless whoever is in the
fire is talking about the angel in the
fire okay all right we're done here guys
I think everybody already saw this every
one more one
more we're at three hours we're at three
hours one more one more one more yeah y
best doesn't doesn't the Bible say
doesn't your Bible say it was the angel
in the burning
the Ang the angel of Yahweh the Malik of
Yahweh is Yahweh he claimed to be Yahweh
creature or created being ex Yahweh the
person of the Angel of the Lord the
pre-incarnate Christ who appeared to
Moses in the fire not some created angel
like Gabriel or something come on Avery
it's fine it's fine no that's basic
theology actually that's that's your
that's the Trinity
correct what does Allah say in the Quran
what does he say yeah he says he says
don't insult oby no he says messenger he
says obey Allah oby the people of
knowledge heyy oey the people of you
hear me ask the people of knowledge hear
me yeah yeah yeah I can hear you what is
Allah say inside the Quran don't ask the
people of
knowled don't
insult what does he say let him finish
he says don't insult their gods why
because they may insult a lot of
ignorance it's not for us to insult any
oh you believe in a trinity oh you
believe in a God man what is this this
is not
the yeah leave the insulting up to the
Quran yeah don't yeah leave it to Allah
don't don't insult them it's not for us
to do did I insult wor of All Creatures
yes anything it's not for it's not for
us to do that and it's not for us to I I
didn't insult no one no you left you
know he mentioned the the angel being
God he started laughing you know yeah
because I laughed at stuff too we're not
offended those are wise words from har
yeah abak but it's for for you to be
strengthened yes these words from Allah
words you be streng means be
strengthened right you a just don't
laugh it they it's not it's
not some people in the chat may have
been offended when no I'm just I'm just
laughing
because it's it's okay bro you're good
okay you're good we we know you you got
a a sweetheart man got a sweetheart may
Allah bless you bro may Allah bless you
AR nice to meet you may Allah bless you
ladies and gentlemen let me
me
everybody okay good thank you Bob thanks
Aron for coming brother of Christ
brother in Christ and Rob who
disappeared on us um thank you all for
coming through and making my throat
sore was a fun discussion for a little
bit just say no homo I did thanks for a
fun discussion hey
thank you for inviting me if you
interrupt me one more time I'mma block
you hey I'mma block you if you interrupt
me again no I said thank you for
inviting me that's what I say don't
interrupt me though let me finish okay
all right all right okay thank you so we
had a an extensive discussion if you
guys want I can open another stream
right now because it's been three hours
I can open another stream and we can
talk about Christianity and go over the
Bible and stuff y'all want to do that
yeah I wna I want to hear the message
that I want to compare it to Islam
necessities of mediators or this that I
want to understand like the I want to
hear the back and forth and like see if
we can come you know good and well you
don't genuinely want to hear no that's
what we left off with of that's what we
left off with on a 10 hour stream we did
a 10 hour stream that's where we left
off I want to finish that right can I
say something because in here in England
it's 3 o'clock in the morning oh you
gota go you're in England I was born
aldah but y you can go ahead and uh
close it all right stream I'm gonna
close this one down